اختلال التوازن عسكريا اكثر ما يخشاه
الاوكرانيون ندركه سيلنسكي جيدا وسيناريو
يصب في صالح روسيا وقد يطيل الحرب اختلال
مطلق لاوكرانيا وحلفائها يراهن عليه بوتن
المسيره الايرانيه الصنع شهيد مئه وست 136
تستنزف الدفاعات الاوكرانيه مصيره ب
20,000$
على الاقل لكن لكل صاروخ وهي تكلفه تحاول
اوكرانيه تجنبها وبالمسيرات ايضا ياتي حلا
اوكرانيا تحديدا لهذه المسيره ما بك ثلاثه
الصينيه صغيره وعمره بطاريتها مناسبه كيف
تحاول التصنيع القنبله المثاليه داخل هذه
المسيره قنابل رخيصه الدبابات الروسيه
التي تكلف الملايين فرق المسيرات
الاوكرانيه تحاول جعل وزن القنبله نصف
كيلو غرام نصف كيلو جرام وهو اكبر وزن
يمكن ان تحمله المسيره دون ان يشكل ذلك
عبئا او جهدا عليها كما يستخدمونها طابعه
ثلاثيه الابعاد في محاوله لصنع غلاف قنبله
خفيف الوزن والهدف الرئيسي هو ان تكون
قادره على حمل متفجرات اللي ازمه اختراق
الدرع الدبابه مسيرته ثلاثه الصينيه باتت
العمود الفقري لقوات الطائرات من دون طيار
الاوكرانيه مزعجه للوصف يمكن هذا ضرب
الاهداف والعوده والمهم تكلفتها اقل من
2000$ مقارنه
بالمسيرات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]